the opportunity is in the uncertainty
and so as long as you can Embrace that
which is why you have to have some
tolerance for risk as an entrepreneur
because you have to pay down your tax of
ignorance which we all have to pay down
every single day for not knowing the
things we should know and the only way
you pay down that tax is that you test
and you iterate and so you just want to
get as many knows out of the way as many
failures out of the way because you're
not actually failing you made progress
it wasn't yes or no did it work or not
it's how well did it work and I think if
you can make even that frame shift
you're like okay well I'm reaching out
to people they're responding but I'm not
getting them on the phone okay well then
you have a scripting issue
okay then you get them on the phone okay
well they're not buying okay well then
it might be an offer issue it still
might be a sales issue depends on why
they're not buying if they're saying you
know it's price it's like you might be
mispriced but you also might just be
really terrible at explaining the value
so you just continue to work your way
down until eventually someone's like
yeah that sounds good and they read you
their credit card over the phone and
you're like holy this is actually
happening and you make your first dollar
and I promise you if you make your first
dollar the second one comes a 100 times
faster than the first one did